Curt Anderson I think it's shaped I
think I think having grown up in Omaha
specifically Nebraska the Midwest has
shaped me quite a bit I think going from
Omaha essentially to the east and New
York specifically put me in a kind of
made me feel a little bit like a
permanent outsider if not an outsider at
least somebody who could see the the
strangeness and magnificence and
ugliness of New York with a certain
amount of awe that hasn't quite left me
also there is a it's a cliche but like
most cliche is a true one that there's
this thing in the Midwest of which which
amounts to a kind of enforced humility
sometimes a mock humility but
nevertheless a sense of you can't you
shouldn't toot your own horn too much
and I think that has stuck with me and
then of course the particulars of my
parents and and and my family background
entirely apart from the Midwest or Omaha
particularly has had a dramatic
influence on who I am I grew up in a
household with lots of books just around
and and with lots of music being played
around and with a sense that my parents
went to the theater the local community
theater so the sense that there was a
culture out there beyond what was on
television was extremely important in to
the degree I've made a life in the
culture industries those were important
so in particular my mother I mean but
both both of my parents I don't
undersell my fathers influenced but my
mother who was kind of an amateur willa
cather scholar and and and just a
voracious reader and somebody who kind
of they both my parents sort of
privileged books and and reading very
highly so
I was sort of hardwired with that same
since very early on not really a pivotal
moment in my child I mean there there
were moments that could have gone wrong
so there I sort of avoided the the
negative pivotal moments if you will but
there wasn't a moment where I suddenly
thought aha I understand I should be
decent and civilized to people or I
should read no it was it was it was a
almost boringly untroubled childhood so
there was no pivot it was it was it was
pleasant and without much in the way of
Epiphany I had the the various kind of
random thoughts that children have I
thought I was told by my parents once
that radiologists but what a radiologist
was and it was just a matter of looking
at x rays I thought that sounded good I
guess I thought I might be a scientist
of some sort as a little kid I began
writing on the school newspaper and
things like that when I was in junior
high school and I guess I probably began
imagining that I could have might have a
life as a writer when I left Omaha for
college I I imagined that I would be
some kind of academic it wasn't until I
got to an academic environment that I
realized I don't think so and and indeed
that the fact that i could write that my
professors and teachers at college
thought I wrote well made me think well
then maybe I can write
you